oh you lost the Charizard I don't know
okay sign the app crashed
go back inside it might be inside you
Shirl's an actual Charizard its outline
yeah we're not up yet Jose let's go back
inside see if you can reach it goddamn
it Brandon everyone's playing Pokemon go
I myself am not really into video games
that said apparently this one is is the
bomb but effectively what I'm trying to
do here is oh my god okay alright so
there is a giant soccer ball that we
have in the back prop room I bought it
for a video that we never did and now
it's time you didn't also plug in one of
these lowers into the air compressor so
you felt the ball my uncle got shot in
the leg with the nail again somehow it
wasn't the fatal wound this thing should
just pop off spitzer hey
right well it's a big soccer ball
pokémon trainer club apparently
everyone's been playing it all week
I feel left out so I'm gonna download it
while we go get one feel like I'm on an
adventure so I should turn on TV a song
yeah all right
I wouldn't I I'd normally wouldn't have
been convinced simply by the fact that
everyone else was playing it but the
fact that Ren got into a car accident
while playing this game really takes it
to the next level for me Ren go into
this game that he went to Vietnam to
find Pokemon
do you know that this world is inhabited
by creatures known as Pokemon will you
help me with my research you seem like a
nice guy sure I'm just looking for
someone like you to help
how did wait that sounds like a sales
pitch there's a Pokemon nearby ok here
are some pokeballs these will help you
catch one oh thanks man
Oh being an Aquarius myself I'm gonna
pick water oh there's a squirrel in my
car got it Oh got it
alright dude how do you feel I feel
great it's not all about your fricking
barber boy burger dick
it's not you to get the spare oh no I
don't I don't see I don't have enough
polka sense okay so how do I see it this
street right now where are you seeing a
stop it's too far away Jake just looking
at his phone walks across almost hit
them
now I haven't got any Pokemon yet though
I would think that it would present them
to you sooner there's a Pokemon you saw
yes
are you 100% sure it's not a Pokemon
it's not a Pokemon oh it's just an item
this is a gym a place where you'll test
your skills at pokemon battle
it looks like you don't have much
experience as a pokemon trainer yet come
back when you've reached level 5 ok I
just got the level 2 super quickly so I
can probably get to level 5 before we
get back from lunch if we hit a couple
more item finds though I can probably
get to level 3 before we get to farmer
boys 3 level 2 apparently I wasn't at
level 2 until it told me that I leveled
up dude there are Pokemon there's one of
you right in front of me how do I do
this click on it click on it ok so now
you're in the photo mode okay music yeah
it's a snake dude then I have to go in
the green do he's biting at me
oh I got it I got it 100 XP curve ball
10x be new Pokemon 500 X be total 610 XP
there's three in here
ah see that dirt ah come on dude yeah we
got beautifly's we got man keys and uh I
got three that's a good start and I'm
more than halfway to level three and I'm
done man
all right Nico's outside right now with
the node crew we're gonna go kick the
soccer ball at him I can't move nor any
further okay no big sermon Oh will Jake
ever become a Pokemon master
will I ever level up my growlithe to
become a arcanine will that soccer ball
hit Carmichael so hard that he falls
down and hurts himself
subscribe to find out well I can't just
Mickey I'm sure going to tell you guys
that you should subscribe if you're not
because you know what YouTube lets us
see how many people are subscribed and
how many aren't in a third of you aren't
subscribed consider subscribing I'll
give you my best Pokemon if you do
that's a total lie but maybe I'll trick
some of you into subscribing